what's a read on this this clash the
first armed clash in five years why now
it's certainly the most significant
armed clash in five years and there was
a volley about 10 months ago but that
was sit see and this is important
because it brings back the very real
notion that things can explode at any
minute and while one doesn't want
overstate the case the North Koreans are
feeling very vulnerable at the moment
then with the 70th anniversary of the
end of the war with the 70th anniversary
of their party coming in two months
they're trying to show force they're
trying to show force does this reflect
any frustration on Kim Jong Un's part
sure it shows that they're frustrated
about us are okay military exercises
that are going on now the propaganda
point that you raised and they're also
consolidating the regime and Kim jong-un
has ousted about sixty percent of the
senior military so as a result he's
probably trying to looks from based on
what's happened in the past what is the
pattern of escalation that you would be
expecting to happen here well hopefully
we won't see much more of it that would
be a good thing but you know it started
small in terms of this tragedy August
fourth with the landmines it's escalated
and unfortunately with the Korean
Peninsula things can escalate more
especially if there is something like a
missile test around the 70th anniversary
of the Korean workers party in early
October every time there's a skirmish I
guess I just assumed that North Korea
started it has there ever been an
instance where South Korea was a clear
instigator no no that's not been the
case and certainly since the Korean War
when North Korea instigated hostilities
but we have to remember things are more
dangerous now in the sense that this is
a young untested leader he may be
consolidating power but there may be
pockets of resentment especially with
the purchase going on that can make for
an unstable North Korea in a region with
a lot of economic instability you
certainly don't want that type of
political instability and I'm glad you
bring that up because China slow down
its rent evaluation this month that
creates a lot of question marks around
the region North Korea must feel the
impact more than others I mean under the
Bloomberg's ECT our function the numbers
show that china is North Korea's biggest
trading partner put those numbers into
context for us because North Korea has a
closed economy and it's clearly very
dependent on China yeah certainly
Scarlett as well said you know it
they're fiercely nationalistic but
they're very
dependent on China you know over seventy
two percent of their imports are from
China forty-two percent of their exports
go to China the only other real player
would be Russia which is having its own
troubles and that could get worse as the
economy gets worse so for North Korea
they're in a bind and we may see a lot
of reaction and turning to external
military is oftentimes what they do and
how to South Korea fit in with all this
as well because isn't China doing more
in terms of ratcheting up its relations
with South Korea well it is China is
doing a tremendous amount the Chinese
and South Korean presidents have met six
times since they both assumed office the
chinese president has met with the North
Korean leader exactly zero times and so
that relationship is very strong
remember that they have over two hundred
and fifteen billion dollars in annual
trade with a new free trade agreement
that was inked in June it could well go
over 300 billion compare that to about
eight billion more or less
optimistically between North Korea and
China it shows you how things are really
held in perspective by the Beijing
regime great perspective well one issue
on which North and South Korea and China
are all in agreement is Japan's
historical atrocities atrocities against
them North Korea as you mentioned
celebrating the 70th anniversary of the
end of World War two in Japan's colonial
rule with a live performance by Western
rock band take a look at this this is
the first ever in North Korea this is
laibach an industrial rock band from
Slovenia performing in Pyongyang on
Wednesday they actually played a sound
of music medley a cover of a Beatles
song and their own version of the final
countdown Kim jong-un certainly not
going about things the same way his
father did in that he is opening up to
some Western influences is it he well
well certainly shows a receptivity to to
some aspects of Western culture of
course there's been the famous NBA visit
by Dennis Rodman but it seemed if you
watch that performance and out and clips
of it that it fell on somewhat muted
ears there was soft appreciation for the
performing audience didn't look
convinced and I convinced it all staff
look at that Lord they look like they're
gonna fall asleep not thrilled they said
it was interesting and I think we'll
leave it at that all right